I wasn't obsessed with a rock.
I certainly didn't see the hand of Iraq
and al Qaeda or anything like that.
I felt that,
uh,
frankly we had our hands full with
Afghanistan.
We needed to do that.
Right.
And like I say,
I think we've done it reasonably well.
We could have done it better.
I felt that Saddam had to go.
I felt it was a good idea to go after
him whether we needed to do it alone.
There's a whole other matter.
Um,
yes,
we had,
you know,
this coalition,
uh,
but it wasn't the same coalition,
like the coalition on Afghanistan.
That was clear.
Uh,
another point was that I believed,
yeah,
that there was a problem with weapons of
mass destruction and it was meant to me
at least,
was a matter of connecting dots.
And that is,
he was a guy,
Saddam Hussein,
who detect five other countries,
a heat attack by rain,
Arac,
Iran,
Saudi Arabia,
Israel,
and Kuwait.
Okay.
So it's interesting that out of the
five,
three were other Arab countries.
And of course he'd attacked his own
people and Curtis,
Stan,
he'd used weapons of mass destruction.
And he was giving $25,000 to every
Palestinian family that had a suicide
bomber in the family.
So there was a connection to terrorism,
there was a proclivity to attack others
and there was a desire to develop
weapons of mass destruction and use
them.
So if you connected the dots,
you saw that this guy really was a
threat and he was behaving as if he were
a threat.
You know,
he didn't want to let inspectors in and
so on and so forth.
Um,
but my sense of it was we should've gone
in,
knocked him out,
got now we could have done that until we
disbanded the Iraqi military.
Once we disbanded the Iraqi military and
disbanded the bath,
he was,
no,
there was no structure.
There was no country.
We were stuck
[inaudible]
that.
I've never been a great believer in
nation building.
Uh,
I think,
you know,
everybody should be prepared to modify
their views.
And Afghanistan taught me that you can
do some nation building and as did
Boston here.
Um,
but you can't do it alone.
I still don't believe the United States
is best equipped to do nation building.
We have a terrible record at it.
We've done it well twice,
Germany and Japan.
But first we flattened them both.
Um,
that's not the sort of thing we're
likely to do in the future.
Nuke somebody or flatten somebody,
you know,
addressed and type thing.
And we're not good at it.
We're not colonialists we don't have a
colonial office.
So for gun to do it,
we have to do it in concert with others,
but really in concert with others,
um,
Afghanistan led me to believe that,
uh,
Iraq,
we didn't disband the bath and the Iraqi
military in concert with others.
From what I understand,
we didn't even disband them in concert
with [inaudible] own administration.
[inaudible].